I was in the middle of filming the
Danish girl Tom Hooper director had let
me have a day off um to fly to LA and
the whole thing felt like a sort of a
bit of a whirlwind
the Oscar goes to Eddie Redmond Kate
Blanchett I couldn't quite believe she
had said my name but what was
interesting is that the excitement was
overwhelming and real and I looked like
a unbehaved like a sort of excitable
puppy
please know this I am fully aware that I
am a lucky lucky man our industry being
an actor is one of those things that
involves a massive amount of luck it
involves skill tenacity hard work highs
lows but it also involves a lot of luck
I wouldn't say winning an Oscar was a
dream because it was sort of Beyond I I
never deemed it possible in my mind to
even dream that big so luck was a
massive huge part of it this belongs to
all of those people around the world
battling ALS when you're portraying
something as specific as ALS the
visibility of it was important and we've
helped to try and shine a spotlight on
on a disease that is one of the most
most brutal I think but definitely when
you're portraying something when the
stakes are real not only for Stephen and
his family but for all the families who
are living with it it feels even more
important to be as rigorous as you
possibly can it belongs to one
Exceptional Family Stephen James
Jonathan and the Hawking children
Stephen have been so supportive from the
second he'd seen the movie there was one
day when we were shooting Theory of
Everything and suddenly I heard a
whisper that Stephen was at the monitors
and that's a pretty terrifying thing and
whilst it's so wonderful to have contact
with the person you're playing if you're
playing a real person it's also deeply
intimidating so he and his family and
just had let me in in a lovely way so
they were thrilled and I promise you I
will look after him uh I will polish him
I will answer his beck and call I will
wait on him hand and foot he's looking
pretty fresh he's still looking shiny it
sits there and it doesn't feel real the
thing about the Oscars they're so shiny
it feels surreal uh to see it